[Music]
destiny to a game we don't know much
about um yeah so here's here's pay why
he came on the show well enough
starcraft ii no snow thanks for nothing
Mike I just joking um what we want talk
about what we want destiny to because we
don't know much about it the the leak
said September 8 release date a couple
weeks ago but that hasn't been confirmed
but there has been this teaser trailer
and it's easier image for destiny to
from Bungie and we've been expecting
this for a while waiting for them to
actually announce it now that there's
been how many expansion 34 destiny take
a 44 yeah dark valero taken king house
of wolves right buyer rise of iron again
taken king was the main one that
actually kind of revamps how the game
works oh I I kind of want just get right
into it Callie what do you want do you
have anything specific you want from
destiny to or broad strokes what do you
hope they do better I'm hoping that
because there were some things in
destiny especially vanilla destiny and
then I felt us in rise of iron also that
just felt like chores like I felt like
grinding for light in a lot of ways the
reward started to taper off for me just
just because when the story is lacking
kind of revisiting the same things and
trying to get into a world could be hard
for me and I think the teaser trailer
sort of indicated that they're leaning
into a little bit more like character
personality or world building especially
cuz he's talking about like at the end
it kind of zooms out and there's there's
this blown out building yeah something
cause clearly happened so I'm hoping
that that is indicative of the not
necessarily own because he's Cade 6 is
very snarky I don't think the whole game
is gonna be snarky but um Nathan Fillion
yes but I'm hoping that there's just a
little bit more incentive to to keep
revisiting I mean I like grinding like I
like grinding for for better route and I
enjoy that and I mean that's why I kept
playing destiny but I think the long
tail was a little a little bit of a
struggle for me with that when taken
came release it seemed like they were
like he said putting you know revamping
the game how it worked in terms of
progression but they also seem like they
were putting a little more emphasis
really starting to put more emphasis on
character again and storytelling with
those cutscenes where they characterize
cade six or the other vanguard leaders
names I forget valla valla hi Cora knows
of all of the time I Corey the world ah
ok so that feeling they're actually
putting more effort into telling that
story because when destiny first
released when we see all these trailers
back before it released in 2014 yeah
September to a 14kt are 15 before it
released a few years ago we kind of saw
like oh people people have a halo and
marathon are going into this MMO space
that combines with shooters and it's
going to be our solar system kind of
like a mass effect of you know like
reimagined solar system we live in and
it was really appealing but then when we
played this game it seemed like there
wasn't as much to as we hoped or at
least we didn't really fully understand
what it was like they kept saying this
is in many ways going to be a platform
for us to build upon and I think those
among us who are excited for different
reasons kept saying well I would still
like to see him explore some cool
storytelling in this cuz I like I like
halo storytelling yeah me too and I just
I love sci-fi story telling in general
and I think there's just so much
potential there and I love the feel of
shooting in this game and that I I want
to combine that with a little something
a little bit more substantial and I
think like I said I think maybe the last
episode of chips has a go on the lobby I
think you know rectifying the stuff with
dinkle bot indicates that they they they
kind of figured that out and they
started to take steps in that direction
so I'm I feel like that is promising for
destiny too yes that make sense they
went through a good year of just quality
of life changes as well as knowing as
you as you had mentioned Kelly that
their story was a little weak and
they're trying to revamp that and I
think they did a good job with that
again with as Mike said to you know with
taking King there was like this huge
kind of push and it's kind of what got
you back in the game two was that there
was so much more kind of interacting
with the NPC's there was more just story
there and I think and hope that they've
learned a lot through this this year
that they found a nice kind of balance
for both
the hardcore and the more casual player
Aaron would love to have some type of
raid make raid matchmaking which is not
in the game yet yeah I need to buy a
table which is debatable because i'm on
one side of the fence I wouldn't want to
do the raid with strangers but it so
what they what they could do is they
could do it like wow where they simplify
the raid um for the raid making group
but then they don't get as good of a
reward for it oh yeah so then they get
like a lower-tier version of like if you
did it normally with your friends or
something like that where any friends he
played I it would be sad if you didn't
have any friends but the thing though is
at least with that they can still
experience the raid albeit maybe not the
full version of it but something similar
still get the raid experience which i
think is very important to the game the
rate is like super key I don't think you
can skip the raid yeah if you really
want to get the full experience and that
was what the bright spot for a rise of
iron for me was there and I really
enjoyed it but I don't I don't know I
like that idea I would get really
nervous I want to do well we'll see I
mean just more matchmaking in general
too because you know nightfall and stuff
like that I don't you know those things
are things that you might have trouble
doing on your own but at the same time
right now they kind of got around that
problem by having lfg stuff on on online
but you can then look for other people
and generally people are pretty
serviceable they know what they're doing
right so and I do you think that would
help maybe more casual players like if
you don't have a group that's like
dedicated to rating like oh we're gonna
raid like every Wednesday or whatever it
is it would be helpful to because if
you're a casual player who's not going
to do that you aren't necessarily
looking for the best Lou anyway so I
mean that is that was the biggest pain
point I think for some of the people in
the office was they did most of what the
game had to offer and they wanted to do
the raid but then it was hard because it
would take somebody to be like okay I'm
going to try to assemble as rain yes
adamant yeah it's a commitment at the
time commitment or even all these things
like you need to carry somebody through
the raid so I can get better gear so you
properly do the raid and it's yeah
there's just like a lot of complication
there but like I said they've added a
lot of good stuff
so like everything they've added also
for this last kind of like hurrah turn
in terms of like their content drop for
destiny one has been good like I think
all that all the quality of life stuff
enhances the game a lot better than what
it was like vanilla destiny where you
have to you know grind materials like
and the most I we walk around and pick
up like relic iron and stuff like that
with a super annoying now it's like way
easier it's just a better kind of
experience to not totally waste your
time I guess they respect your time a
little bit more I also definitely want
the app to make a comeback cuz im so
much gear it's like super easily i have
to do the vault garbage love it it I
love the app I used to when I first
arted playing destiny I would like go to
work and like just beyond the app
looking like reading the lore because I
like couldn't stop thing about destiny
yeah you played on a Nintendo switch you
could use the app on the tablet God what
should I was ever come out on switch I'd
never wearing that no it never baby what
if it comes out on pc then you can now
get those people that maybe don't have a
console and wanted to play it and maybe
you can somehow play with pc i no
windows or sorry I know Xbox one has
done a good job of like cross play with
Windows it's just kind of right so it's
kind of there I know street fighter 5
has it with ps4 and PC kind of so it'll
be interesting if they can figure that
out because i think that would kind of
expand the playerbase do you guys expect
is going to be like sort of a nice small
gimmicky vr component not like a huge
mission but like pry on your gear look
at this little area I mean I'd be
shocked if it didn't have it I think it
really i think i'm not talking about
anything substantial or like this is a
selling point for the game well because
there is like you get content first on
ps4 maybe there's a PS VRE we know that
for sure though I mean with destiny like
was the original the current basil
together but like we talked about a two
out of three platforms is coming out on
have V our support right yeah and
they're obviously not gonna try to sell
the game and or have it live and die by
to be our support because I don't think
will be substantial but yeah I'd be
shocked if they didn't rise a little bit
of something to give people just like
just a little taste of you know like a
different way of looking at the
sort of being within it last question I
put money on it cuz you guys don't I
don't think I owe a bet ya know i think
i wanna you should mention bets um Eric
pay ya before taken king came out god
this is supa you and I had a bet to see
who can get to level 42 new level cap
first yeah so jon was gonna roll
something here this is me and you
playing of a I believe he's gonna bring
audio up so here's your Irish access me
of course that's you here with Bonnie
save it up and apology if I'm talking
over this cuz I don't I don't have no
Fitz audio right now hey Luke is there
audio playing for the stream dead
silence yeah so this is the stream we
did and I turned a bunch of these in
you're like holy [ __ ] i just got some
level 37 in like 10 seconds and mien tay
had a steak dinner riding on who gets a
level 40 first and yeah cut away from oh
my god yeah we saw nothing you blew it
we saw nothing at all right well i won
we ended up I ended up because I got to
it so easy that within like 10 minutes
we turned in bounties we had saved up
before 10 king came out and I got to
level 40 right before you only because
you're like I could crush you right now
get to level 40 so then I just like to
start it I know you know what a lot of
had that I want to have all I forgot to
stake I got you a sandwich though I
bought you lunch was it a steak sandwich
yeah really i don't know if you got me
solutions which is fine yeah sushi is a
good alternative i think so we we didn't
think that turning in all our bounties
would just get us to level 40 yeah but
somehow it did that also you have the
stupid cloak that gives plus 10
percentage you hadn't do you i did
wearing it I didn't hit it they give it
to the beginning of thinking you didn't
just use this meka Bob cheat or your for
your new subclass yes um whatever but
yeah I did lose this also if you just
watch this another fun fact quality of
life thing is you know how you had to go
here to turn in your bounty to have to
do that anymore I know that in your
mentor oh you had to turn in year one
bounties to him okay anyway okay that's
one yeah they cycle again it's
two years since that happened uh it's
actually funny i was watching the stream
we both look pretty young huh shut up
what anyway okay sweet so that's destiny
to we hope we're going to get out of it
and what they're gonna learn from the
expansions of Destiny release again it
was a rumored September its release day
without that confirmed yet marks 30th
funny's going to be making the
announcement that's the room are you
Lara tomorrow that's today the 29 you
yeah my god March mm-hmm okay cool
tomorrow couple days after your birthday
yeah that sucks but he behind years
prior Oh keep an eye on gamespot.com for
the announcement or whatever is coming
tomorrow the stream that what it is dude
you can be doing a stream no I think
it's just like a [ __ ] Fowler trailer
cool yeah so that will be on gamespot
com you go check that out and stay tuned
here as until sep tember when we will
tell you how this game is maybe I feel
like I feel like we'll see something at
e3 I don't know if we'll get like
hands-on or anything like that but i
wouldn't be shocked if we saw something
at e3 we have to write yeah so yeah I
guarantee oh you're on the hook I don't
know why I did that
you